>> From The Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Carl Zimmer: This
session is going
to be called The Emergence
of Life in the Lab.
The last session we learned about
how to get clues to the origin
of life by going to lots of
interesting and difficult to get
to places, like the
bottom of the ocean,
and earlier someone had mentioned
about the recent discovery
of fossils, which may be the oldest
fossils of life on earth dating back
over 3.7 billion years
which come from Greenland.
These are tough places to get
to and you get little clues,
sometimes very indirect clues.
You know, if you're
looking at things
that are alive today you're not
really looking at life as it began,
and if you're looking at fossils
you're looking at these very kind
of faint shadows of
life that once was.
So another way to think
about the origin of life,
another way to study it is to
say, hey, it's life and it's made
up of molecules so let's just put
them together and test them out
and see if we can make life
or if we can carry out some
of the actions we think were
important for making life
and let's just do it in the nice
comfortable confines of a lab
where you can get lots of coffee
when you need it and
everything is great.
Not that easy, actually, either.
And so we're going to be hearing
from a scientist who does this kind
of research, as well a historian
and an anthropologist about sort
of the culture of life in the lab.
And so we'll start
with Steve Benner.
Steve is a Distinguished Fellow
in the Westheimer Institute
at the Foundation for
Applied Molecular Evolution
and he has taught at Harvard
and other places, as well.
I've had the privilege of writing
about Steve's work several
times over the past few years.
I wrote a piece in 2013 for the New
York Times about some of his musings
about whether life is more likely
to have originated here on earth
or have it started on
Mars and come here.
So if you just Google our names
in the New York Times
that should pop up.
And I do remember, I just wanted to
recall like when I first met Steve,
which was awhile ago
and may have been, gosh,
maybe 15 years ago or something.
I went to - I was going
to do a profile
of Jack Shostack [Assumed Spelling],
who is also a very important person
in the origin of life research
who is building these
kind of protocells.
And Steve was visiting and they were
just hanging out in a coffee shop
and they just said - Jack
just said, just meet us here.
So I sit down and I'm introduced to
Steve, who I've never met before,
and he says, so what
do you think, you know,
how much money do you think it would
take to set up a lab to be able
to invent life from scratch,
like how much money given what
we know, just what do you think?
And I just thought about
it and said, $20 million.
And he just paused and he
thought about it, it's like,
yeah, that sounds about right.
So that gives you a sense
of how Steve thinks and
without further ado.
[ Technical Difficulty ]
>> Steve Benner: This is on?
I guess it is on.
This is quite a diverse group and
I'm going to start first by talking
to those of you whose only
interaction with science was
in a bad eighth grade middle
school science course,
where you were taught about
these scientific methods,
which had questions and
hypothesis and observations,
entirely constructed experiments
that tested the mechanism
or the hypothesis or
not the hypothesis,
but really missed all
the basic issues.
And so I mean I've given up
judging science fair projects,
but you can actually look at some
of the problems that you have,
like here's a guy who has
got a poster who wants
to know why chicks dig
me, there's a hypothesis.
Remember all these posters
in a science fair have
to state a hypothesis and the
background and all the rest of it,
but rarely is the language discussed
as to what language will be
used to answer the question.
This is certainly a problem
with the origins of life.
Now what do you expect,
a mathematical formula,
do you expect a chemical reaction,
do you expect a geological model?
And, of course, for any of
you who have a small child
and you say chicks dig me because
I have nice hair, the question is
but why do nice hair
have chicks dig me?
And, of course, if you're
a good Darwinian at the end
of the day you say that, well,
chicks dig this nice gentleman
because they think
that his DNA paired
with theirs would give their
offspring the highest chances
of surviving itself, getting
married and having children.
But, you know, here's a great guy
who had an interesting question,
will there be minorities in heaven?
That's not his question, his
question is is there a heaven?
And then some science
fair adviser insisted
on a purpose hypothesis variable
format and so he had to come
up with a new poster,
which is unfortunate.
Now simple questions are easy
to answer, like this one,
how long will a dead body float?
[laughter] Right?
And, of course, answers can
also be put to practical use.
Here's a science fair project
called Getting Away With It,
proper corpse disposal,
in case you're interested.
But keep in mind that it's the
simple questions that are easy
to answer by this hypothesis based
direction, but not the big ones,
and unfortunately the big
questions are the interesting ones.
So I got tired of my
kid being abused
by eighth grade science fair project
leaders, so I wrote this book, Life,
the Universe and the Scientific
Method, a copy of which I have here
which I will autograph for
you if anybody wants one.
Basically, science is not hypothesis
testing, it's a back and forth
between two sides or maybe
five sides or maybe even more,
but everybody is trying to
place the burden of proof
on something, somebody else, right?
Nothing is proven in science,
nothing actually is disproven
in science, Carl Popper [Assumed
Spelling] and our education
of scientists notwithstanding.
It's an operational
science as the back
and forth can be very well
organized and people understand
who has the burden of
proof, but when you say
that metabolism comes
before biopolymers,
this is metabolism
first or DNA first,
that becomes a confused
burden of proof to assign,
or life arose at deep-sea thermal
vents, which is what I put in just
after hearing the last talk.
These are not so much yes or no
questions as what do you really mean
and given the state of the
field discussions are often,
you'll see this semantically
confused
without understanding
where the burden is.
And really we have to decide
who must show what in order
for this field to advance?
Now we've been involved in
what we call the four paths
to understand origin.
It's a little Chinese,
a little Confucianism,
but the northern path is
where we try to build life.
And the pieces, the bottom, the
right, the eastern path is the path
which we discussed a
moment ago by where we try
to construct our own life forms.
Obviously, we are desperately trying
to get married to get us an alien
from Mars, if we can just
get another species from Mars
who arose independently of Mars we
would have a great insight to this.
But I'd like to start
with the bottom one,
which actually somewhat
makes the most sense, right?
If you have a biosphere
full of life, you know,
you might as well try to
look at that biosphere
and see how it might have worked.
And keep in mind your problem
is that as we have shown
on this green tree there
is a natural history,
which relates all the organisms
that we know to each other
by common molecular structures.
Now that's a bit circular because
the way we look for organisms
on earth is by looking for
those molecular structures,
so it is conceivable that
there is a shadow bias here.
And that's Carol Cleland's [Assumed
Spelling] term, which might be
under our feet, which uses
a different biochemistry
which we don't see because we
don't know how to look for it.
And in some sense Carl Woese,
who you've already seen a picture
on the slide, has perhaps
discovered one of those many years,
I don't know 50 years ago about now.
But working backwards in time
we are using sort of a process
and this process is a
principle of mineral motion.
We use it, for example, when we
construct Indo-European languages.
This is just the Indo-European
language of Slavic, Germanic,
Romance languages, Celtic,
which has the word for snow,
it's present in all
of those languages.
Of course, in some cases it's quite
recognizable, so German it's schnee
and in Slavic it's snijeg,
and French, of course,
the Romance language decided
that s-n was hard to pronounce
so they dropped the s-n so you have
just the words beginning with n,
like nieve in Spanish
or neige in French.
What's important, of course,
is now you can actually look
at the structures and you see them
in common from all the descendants.
And the principle of minimal motion,
some people call it
maximum parsimony,
is to say that if I assume
that languages change as little
as possible I will try to
construct the ancient word for snow
in the last common ancestor of all
the modern Indo-European languages
with a little, the smallest
amount of phonetic or change.
And to do that you can come up with
the word snig, which is written
at the top of this chart, as to what
you would say to an Indo-European
if you were to encounter
him or her in the street
and wanted to talk about snow.
Now if you put these words
into natural context they get
more than just that, right?
And the natural context,
all of a sudden you realize
that Indo-European has more
words that tells you not just
about what you would say to the
Indo-European if you encounter him
or her on the street, but
it also tells you something
about the Indo-European society,
specifically, that live in a place
where it snowed which
rules out say Zaire.
But the reconstruction,
the Indo-European language
does not have a word for gold,
it does not have a word for
silver, it does not have a word
for tax exempt and mutual bonds,
but it does have words for dogs
and for sheep and for oxen
and for pigs, they have grain,
they can put them in vehicles which
have wheels, and they can count
to 100, and we know that
by looking at the context
of the modern languages
set into a model
of how you infer ancient
ancestral structures
from the structures
of descendent words.
So we could do the same thing now
by replacing the phonetic
letters by molecular structures.
And let me just do something that's
important because I'm a chemist
and you've heard Wally Gilbert,
mentioned he was a physicist
turned molecular biologist.
We chemists look at
molecules atom by atom, right?
We don't - and we look
down upon and you'll find,
probably get the tension in
my voice, we resent personally
that Wally Gilbert, a physicist
turned molecular biologist who looks
at structures only letters at
a time, does not look at atoms,
but nonetheless wins the
Nobel Prize in Chemistry.
That gets us real tense.
But let me go back,
and I'm not sure,
who looks at their vitamin pills?
Please, raise your hands
if you actually study?
So if you look at this you'll notice
that there's a whole bunch of stuff
in here and what these
generally are are what we'll call
enzyme cofactors.
You've heard enzymes a couple
minutes ago, these are the catalysts
that catalyze transformations.
I've just put down here
a structure of ATP.
ATP is well known as being a
very common molecule involved
in phosphate transfer,
phosphorylation,
but also energy economy of cells.
And I've structured it to show you
that there's a piece of RNA attached
to it, and the black part is the
phosphate that's actually been
transferred, the orange part is RNA.
And all modern organisms, at
least that we know of on life
on earth, have ATP in them.
And so we infer from that and
the principle of minimal motion
that the last universal
common ancestor,
which charmingly has the
name LUCA, also had ATP.
But, of course, it's more than that,
it's the last universal
common ancestor had ATP it was
also phosphorylatic.
Now that's a belief that
requires a logical premise,
is sort of the same kind of logic
that if I gave you a T-rex tooth,
right, and it looks like it's ideal
for chewing meat then you infer
that the T-rex was a meat-eater.
That's a deep Darwinian
statement, actually.
But the bottom line is that if
all descendants of LUCA have ATP,
the ancestor LUCA had ATP,
all descendants use ATP
to transfer phosphate, therefore,
the ancestor transferred phosphate.
And if you go back to your vitamin
pills you'll notice that these are
so important that there's niacin,
which I have as the structure there.
I'm thinking it shows up
on the screen, does it?
We have, of course,
thiamine, we have coenzyme A,
which is in the vitamin
pills is pantothenic acid.
All of these molecules end up in
your metabolism with a reactive part
in black and an RNA piece
attached to it doing nothing.
And the reason why we
know it's doing nothing is
because for all those structures
I put a little blue structure,
which is the same molecular
structure
that can do exactly the same
thing as the RNA cofactor can do,
but it is not used very widely in
enzymology, the ancestral state.
LUCA had RNA attached to everything.
Now that leads to an obvious
question, it was a question raised
by Harold White, a chemist at the
University of Delaware in 1976,
it was raised by Cornelius Visser,
a chemist, and Richard Kellogg,
a chemist, both in the
Netherlands in 1998.
That paper in 1998 is how biotin's
reactivity can be understood,
biotin being one of the things you
eat, in terms of the RNA world.
We're 10 years ahead of
the molecular biologists.
I'm hoping Wally is not
watching this because I'm going
to get a long letter from him.
We're 10 years ahead of the
molecular biologists because we look
at the chemistry and, of course,
that paper from the 1970s is what
persuaded me that the RNA world was
so likely to be the case
because it explained so much
about the molecules that we
have in our everyday life.
Everybody with me?
Cool. So it turns out that
there's lots of other things.
The RNA world, of course, as
you've already heard today,
is defined as an episode
in natural history on earth
where RNA was the sole
genetically encoded biocatalyst.
It explains these RNA cofactors with
RNA handles to bind RNA enzymes.
Again, DNA later emerged,
more stable genetics,
you heard that a few minutes ago.
And then RNA catalysts later
emerged and made proteins.
That structure in blue and
orange is the ribosome,
it's the machine that
makes proteins.
And I've color coded it,
so the orange is RNA.
You've probably got the thread here.
The blue is proteins slapped
on the surface, which help out.
But the ribosome making proteins
is an RNA catalyst and that is
in addition to the structure
of the RNA world cofactors.
Now for this to make sense, okay,
RNA world must not only
have had the cofactors,
but also the reactions
that use the cofactors.
The RNA world must have
had a complex metabolism
with [inaudible] metabolism,
that is oxidation and reduction,
because that's what niacin RNA
cofactors do and that's what Flavin
or riboflavin is what's in
your bottle cofactors do.
Claisen carbon-carbon bonding
reactions - I won't go through all
of the chemical jargon
that describes the reactions
the RNA world was catalyzing.
But if this theory or if this
explanation, if this why question
for your eighth grade science
fair posters to make any sense,
it's got to be the case that not
only did the RNA world have those
cofactors but it used them
and it must have used them
in a complex metabolism.
And we actually in 1989 wrote
this paper with Andy Ellington,
now at the University of
Texas, modern metabolism
as a polemicist [Assumed Spelling]
of the RNA world, and then in 1993
in the book that you've already seen
mentioned we actually wrote 50 pages
to write out all the details of
what that metabolism looked like.
And so we've heard already
this is the same thing now
with the niacin cofactor.
You heard a moment ago about
Bill Martin's view, Bill Martin,
a bunch of people looking at organic
biomolecules as if they're strings
of letters, not looking at the
individual atoms and they had come
up with a conclusion that
completely denies this.
Now in our view that's wrong,
their view, of course, we're wrong,
so we can go back and forth trying
to shift the burden of proof
to each other as we duke it
out in the bold alpha male
world of modern science.
Okay, fair enough.
So that's a problem for us because
working backwards in time is going
to fail to get us anywhere
near origins, right?
You believe Bill Martin,
you don't agree with this,
but remember if you believe Bill
you can't explain the RNA cofactors.
You can explain the RNA
cofactors - this is what I think I
like about my Willard Vandermyde
Klein [Assumed Spelling] moments.
I mean I don't know for those
of you are into philosophy,
Klein basically made a remark
about Carl Popper's statement
that science was associated
with disprovable hypotheses.
And Klein's comment was, no, you
can't disprove anything either
because there's always
these auxiliary hypotheses.
The experiment failed,
disproves the theory?
No, no, it proves the
machine was broken, right?
I mean there's all sorts of stuff.
But one of the nice
things that Klein does talk
about is these packages of
logical statements that you choose.
So Martin is right, can't
explain RNA cofactors,
can explain RNA cofactors
then Martin is wrong.
And so what emerges, we have
to really be forced now to go
into the north quadrant
of this plot.
We actually have to
worry about this model.
And, of course, what going
backwards in time has done
for us is not nothing, it
has done something for us.
It does suggest an origin
that must be dependent on RNA,
that's what that story
has done for us.
The story is, and there's John
Luke Picard [Assumed Spelling]
with Q [Assumed Spelling]
who is flitting in and out
of the continuum, taking John
Luke Picard precise as the time
where life originated on earth.
The argument is that
RNA emerged able
to catalyze template directed
synthesis of with errors,
but where the errors are replicable
if you're a good hardcore molecular
Darwinist that's all you need
to have this process of
having kids with mutants
and having the better ones
survive and the worst ones die,
produce all the behaviors
that we value in life.
Now the first person I know
who did this was Alex Rich [Assumed
Spelling] in 1962 and, frankly,
he wrote that out much better
than Woese, Orgel or Crick.
It was a very clear statement.
And Alex died last year,
he's a great hero of mine,
but he was also very persuasive.
But I did not know about it until
I gave a seminar where he was
in the audience where I cited
Woese and Crick, Orgel and Woese.
So now there are molecules.
Phil Holliger, actually a former
student in my lab, for those of you
who have been in my lab you'll
know that I will take credit
for everything you do ever after.
I actually had nothing
to do with this.
He's at MRC in Cambridge, he made an
RNA molecule that is actually able
to catalyze the template directives
of RNA, but they're replicable.
So are we done, done
and done, right?
Well, not so fast.
This is a detailed hypothesis.
I would prefer the word model.
You can say that the burden of
proof has shifted and I can insist
that others now disprove
the hypothesis.
Well, good luck with that.
And so the question
now comes back to us,
how can this model meet a convincing
burden of proof, convincing people,
the people needing
conviction are creationists,
as well as our professional
colleagues in molecular biology,
as well as of course the chemists?
And that's a big problem because
we should be able to assemble
in the modern lab components of
RNA from prebiotic precursors,
especially since we're not
operating under the constraints
of a prebiotic soup, right?
I mean compared to the prebiotic
earth modern molecular biologists
have the power of God, right?
And we ought to be able to go
back and do this trivially.
And so, but keep in mind, I'm
now going to pass these samples
around because this is
what we're looking for.
This is a stromatolite, this is 3.4
billion years old, it's not the 3.7
that has just recently - and
I expect these to come back.
I do, however, want you - this
looks like an honest crowd, yes.
But I just wanted to -
there's Cambrian explosion,
that's actually somebody that
you might say looks like you,
that's the origin of
life sort of, I guess.
I mean, but there's twice as much
time between the origin of earth
and this guy as there is
between this guy and you.
So you should keep that in mind when
you are - so here, pass these around
and then drop them off in
the back when you're done.
>> Set them down here?
>> Steve Benner: There, yes.
Well, so we ought to
be able to do it.
And what's happened when
people have tried and it's
about 50 years of failure?
Ah, so what does one do?
Now you've already
heard this before,
what you want to do is you want
to in this business
follow the paradoxes,
you want to understand what it
is that is so God damn difficult?
And then you want to go back and
look at that with intense focus,
one at a time, because there
will be one God damn thing
after another as you
go through this.
So I've put out five
paradoxes for you.
One is the so-called tar paradox,
which is if you give enough energy
to organic matter, which
happens to not have access
to Darwinian evolution, you
don't get life, you get tar,
and it's a well validated
observation
and you probably have validated
it yourself in the kitchen
if you've left the oven on
too long, right, you get tar.
The phosphate paradox, we'll
talk about in a minute.
Phosphate is the linking
groups in RNA.
It's hard to get phosphate
in the presence of calcium
because you get something
that looks like this.
This is apatite, it's
calcium phosphate.
The other thing that is
also possible is your bones.
So lovely, these are
lovely stones, by the way.
Yes, I don't mean to disrupt your
- so the third paradox we'll talk
about is the water paradox.
We say that life requires water, but
water is a very corrosive solvent
and it basically destroys all
the biopolymers and a good deal
of the other molecules,
including a lot
of the cofactors that I mentioned.
Next, suppose you get over that, you
get the tar, manage to evade tar,
prevent the organic molecules
from devolving to get asphalt,
you manage to get the phosphate,
you manage to assemble
RNA, you manage to keep it.
The next paradox that
you will encounter is
that once you've made the RNA it's
not stable enough to accumulate,
and so you have to worry
about recovering the RNA.
And, finally, even if you can keep
RNA it's far easier to get RNA
that destroys RNA as a catalyst,
we can do that roughly one molecule
in 10 to the 14th of RNA molecules
is a catalyst able to destroy RNA.
Much more easy to get stuff
that destroys than to create.
We don't know the actual likelihood
or the odds for making RNA,
but it's somewhere
in the 10 to the 30s.
So let me go through and just tell
you a little bit about what goes
on here when you focus
on these paradoxes.
And I'll start with the tar
paradox, which is well validated,
it's known in sugars,
there's sucrose.
Who here, rock candy,
raise your hands?
That was in seventh grade, right?
So, but if you heat it a little bit
you'll get caramelization, right,
and you're looking at it, right?
More heat, more carmel, and
this is well known to you and,
unfortunately, that's the sugar
but RNA has a sugar component,
which is unfortunately R. Since
Miller's experiment was named,
I want to point out the
power of rhetoric in science.
Left is Stanley, himself, the great
man who arguably founded modern bio
or prebiotic chemistry, with
his machine in a press photo.
The right picture shows
what it actually looks like.
What Miller showed is that if
you put energy into organics
without Darwinism you get tar.
So why do you get tar?
Well, the answer is because of
the - chemists, I'll talk to you,
we talk about enolization
and aldol reactions -
for the non-chemists I just want
you to look for C double bond O,
carbon joined by two
bonds to an [inaudible]
because that can do these reactions.
Enolization, which is shown
here, and aldol addition,
which is also shown here,
that give you complexity
which looks like that.
And, of course, I've only
put part of the complexity,
and we've worked out
all these reactions.
One of the problems with ribose is
it also has a C double bond O unit
and, therefore, it can
enolize, there's that reaction,
and reacted with itself
and it can form asphalt.
In fact, it's so bad that in 1995
Stanley Miller wrote a paper,
which I've written on this slide,
where he says and I'm quoting now,
stability considerations preclude
the use of ribose and other sugars
as prebiotic agents, they fall
apart, ribose falls apart,
it follows that ribose and any
other sugars were not components
of the first genetic material,
and that's a real problem
for the RNA world molecules
because if there's no R,
ribose, there's no RNA.
So, you know, we've been now
for 15 years making this plea
for minerology partly because when
I was a kid I was a rock hound,
and life did not begin
in a Pyrex baking pan
or in a Pyrex beaker
for that matter.
It began in a mineral environment,
and I'm going to actually pull up -
here's a wonderful mineral
for you, actually hard to say,
these are tourmalines, these would
probably be better on the picture,
it's even better down the
street in the jewelry store.
Tourmalines contain the
element boron and boron
with oxygen gives borate and borate
is something that gets excluded
from rock forming minerals and
comes to the surface and it washes
out into alkaline streams.
You've heard serpentinization,
that's coming from peridot.
There's an example of peridot,
which you can actually
see the serpentinization.
Borate has a magical property,
it binds to two adjacent
OH hydroxyl groups.
Ribose has adjacent
Once borate binds it causes
the whole molecule cyclizing,
get rid of the C double
bond O group.
The C double bond O
group is what gives you
so much trouble in
prebiotic chemistry.
It also happens to guide the
reactions of carbohydrates and,
in fact, if I just go back to
the picture I showed you before,
borate constrains the reactivity to
just that little region of the plot.
Wonderful, so there's a lot
of stories on the tar paradox,
that's just one, but let me now
move on to the phosphate paradox,
which comes from the fact that it's
hard to get high concentrations
of phosphate in the presence
of calcium, which precipitates
as apatite, which is now
circulating throughout the room.
And apatite does not phosphorylate
ribose or sugars and, in fact,
does not allow itself to easily
go into the backbone of RNA.
But here is a shout out for
astrobiology because astrobiology
as an institute, the
NASA/Astrobiology Institute,
went out of its way to create
what we call multi-disciplinarity
but then they did so by
having a virtual institute.
They did not require universities
to move people from place to place
and build a building to house them.
Multi-disciplinarity is certainly
accessible by the internet.
And so you've got to really enjoy
browsing geological reports.
I don't know who, the people
who are geologists, you sit back
and I'm sitting in the sunroom
one day doing the crossword
and then I pick up
this geology report,
and I notice here gypsum
occurs within the sequences,
geological sequences, containing
luneburgite [Assumed Spelling].
Huh, well, okay, what
the hell is gypsum,
what the hell is luneburgite?
Well, gypsum is calcium sulfate.
Mineralogists have this name
just to keep the club small.
Luneburgite is a magnesium
boro-phosphate.
And the fact that they occur
together has significance.
So what does it mean if
gypsum, which is a combination
of magenta calcium and yellow
sulfate and luneburgite,
which is a red magnesium,
a blue boron
and a green phosphate,
occur together?
Well, as I mentioned, the phosphate
problem in the RNA first model has
to do with the need for a
lot of phosphate to make RNA
and phosphate green and calcium
magenta generally precipitate
as magenta green apatite.
But in the presence of borate what
that geological report
told us was that, no,
if you actually have
borate present, blue,
it will sequester the
green phosphate away
from the magenta green apatite.
And, in fact, instead of having the
two boxes on the left, where calcium
and phosphate precipitated
to get useless apatite,
and magnesium sulfate precipitate
to get useless epsonite,
borate present, phosphate,
borate and magnesium go together
to give you luneburgite and
calcium and sulfate are separated.
You've rescued the
phosphate from the calcium
and this also happens
in the laboratory.
So a different question, right?
A minute ago we used boron to
stabilize organics to prevent them
from forming tar, here
we're now using boron
to sequester phosphate
away from calcium
so that it doesn't get
lost in a useless mineral.
Two questions, same answer,
it's a wonderful thing.
And it turns out that
luneburgite does a wonderful job,
not only in making the phosphate
available, but once the nucleoside,
which I have drawn on the
right-hand corner of that slide,
extracts the borate out of the
mineral it then gets itself
phosphorylated and,
more to the point,
it actually gets phosphorylated
just at one place,
the five prime position which
is where you want it to.
By the way, we're talking
about continuity, right?
You don't want to have a step happen
and have an intelligent
designer have to come in
and take the material that
was made in the first step
of prebiotic chemistry
and redo it, purify them,
and put it into the second step.
If you can get all these
steps working together,
okay, you're in great shape.
I've actually put a structure
up here, which is nucleoside,
it's a building block for RNA.
You might ask where do
nucleosides come from?
In a desert about four months
ago Tom Corel [Assumed Spelling]
actually proposed a route for
this, which I've shown here.
So what we're doing here, building
what will emphasize the weakness
of this model.
The weakness of this model
is it is still discontinuous,
which gets us from gases like carbon
dioxide and hydrogen, hydrogen oxide
and dinitrogen and
methane, to formaldehyde.
I wish that Jim had been here
because he actually wrote the
distinctive review of this.
We then get to the other processes.
In step-wise form,
going from atmospheric
to in this case ribose
nucleosides phosphates.
How we doing?
A lot of chemistry.
Obviously, the next question is even
if you make RNA how do
you get it to accumulate?
Well, it turns out that
minerals in a desert also bind
to the RNA and stabilize it.
This is work that's just
appearing from a release
of Beyonde [Assumed Spelling] in our
group, where she is absorbing RNA
that is made onto the support.
And so the next question is even
if you can keep RNA it's far easier
to destroy RNA than it is - easier
to get RNA that destroys RNA
than it is to get RNA
that makes RNA.
How much time do I have?
I'm looking at three minutes, but
we started quite late, right, so?
But let me just spend the
three minutes now just
to give you the final
paradox, right?
Keep in mind that RNA is a bad
reservoir of catalytic activity.
The reason it took so long
for Tom Cech and Sid Altman
to win the Nobel Prize,
finding catalysis out of RNA,
it is not a very good molecule,
and that's because it has only
four building blocks and not a lot
of functional groups, like you
have in amino acids and proteins,
which is what makes proteins
so powerful as catalysts.
However, if you again do
what I showed you before,
looking at the modern life forms
and going backwards in time,
you'll discover that LUCA
does not just have RNA,
it has RNA with these magenta
side chains attached to it
which are functional groups.
In fact, some of them are very
close to the functional groups
that are found in proteins.
And so maybe, maybe, maybe
at some point LUCA decided maybe
before it invented translation,
maybe terran life may have tried to
improve the catalytic power of RNA
by adding functionality
to the standard basis.
Now, of course, you and I
descended from an organism,
which as Mary pointed out, which
the winners did not do that.
But maybe we as synthetic biologists
can create an alternative path
and do what natural
history did not do on earth.
And so this is now not backwards
in time, it's not forwards in time,
it's the east quadrant, where
we're actually going to take DNA,
which I'm just going to
use the Lego structures
to illustrate how DNA
works with a big
and a small base, with
prongs and holes.
We're going to complete
this Lego set,
so we actually have all possible
combinations of big basis
and small basis and prongs and
acceptors, there's the chemistry,
there's some more chemistry.
We're going to add functional
groups to them and we're going
to have our own little private
personal evolving Darwinian system,
following a path that terran life
could have taken but did not.
And the reason why we can do this is
because we are Gods compared
to the prebiotic earth.
So I won't describe this,
as we're out of time.
I will just say that we are
able to apply Darwinism.
Keep in mind that we do pay
the bills in our laboratory
by binding to cancer cells.
Why? Because that's a much more
important thing to bind to.
But once you have just four letters
in your nucleic acid alphabet
and you try to evolve from that four
letter alphabet DNA or RNA molecules
that bind to cancer cells, but not
to non-cancer cells that's a lack
of specificity, it's hard to do.
But if you add letters to the
genetic alphabet you get those that,
in fact, bind quite well.
So there is the paradoxes that
you can go back by focusing
on these individual details,
bringing in the geological
environment and the minerals.
Well, you can ask were
these minerals
and deserts present on early earth?
Bob Hasen [Assumed Spelling] and I
have had a long discussion of this.
Were deserts available on early
earth we could have had these things
evaporate, a similar discussion?
What's nice is that the minute our
geologists look for [inaudible]
and borate they discover it.
So luneburgite, for example
is unstable to metamorphosis,
it gives monazite, it gives
apatite, it gives tourmaline,
but you can find all
of those minerals
in 3.8 billion-year-old
geometric, metasedimentary rocks
from Greenland, which
Carl mentioned.
Are deserts available
on early earth?
Joe Kirschvink says, no,
water inventory much too high
for there to be any dry land.
So Joe has suggested the Kirschvink
model, which was that all you've got
to do is go to Mars, which
has always had less water.
The logic tree, of
course, is you've got
to decide now whether the
burden of proof has been met?
RNA first, yes or no?
If it's no you have a
different set of problems.
Benner's chemistry, if the
answer is no, my response is, no,
get your own God damn chemistry.
If it's yes, you need an
oxidized desert and also a desert.
Can we have those in Mars?
You've got to decide if the answer
is no - sorry, can you have them
on earth, then you have to
decide, if the answer is no, well,
then Mars is an option, if not,
you can actually have the
discontinuous model occurring
on earth.
With that, let me stop.
I've said too much
chemistry, that's for sure,
but I think the chemistry
is very important.
And we'll go on to the next.
[ Applause ]
>> Carl Zimmer: For the
interest of time we're going to -
we can take questions at
the end from everybody.
We're going to do our
best to catch-up a bit.
We may run a little
bit late at the end
of this session, but
we'll do our best.
And I guess you can see why
whenever I interview Steve I make a
recording, I can go
back and reflect.
Anyway, our next speaker
will be Luis Campos,
who is an Associate Professor of the
History of Science at the University
of New Mexico and the
Secretary Elect of the History
of Science Society and will soon
be the next Blumberg NASA Library
of Congress Chair of
Astrobiology here.
So, Luis, please come join us?
>> Luis Campos: Good morning.
Soon, we are confident, life
will appear in a test tube
and our world will
never be the same.
Although this passage comes
from a book published in 2000,
the idea that it's merely a matter
of time before life can be created
in the test tube is hardly
a new one and it's come
in many different flavors
at many different times.
In 1837, for instance, by
running an electric current
through a laboratory apparatus
the experimenter, Andrew Crosse,
was astonished to discover
crawling out one day a species
of a caras mite, and a
heretofore unknown one at that.
These experiments in electrobiology
proved to be remarkably popular.
Although his laboratory set-up
was later disparaged by critics
as an obstrico-galvanic apparatus,
his efforts were described
by the Historian James
Secort [Assumed Spelling]
as the most famous experiment of
the first half of the 19th Century.
For most readers, he concluded,
the creation of life
was an experimental fact
by the end of January 1837.
I want to start off today
by suggesting that claims
to have artificially
synthesized new forms of life
in the laboratory are not only oddly
recurring, but a characteristic
and a regular feature of the
history of modern biology.
From late 19th Century announcements
of Luther Burbank's' new creations
in fruits and flowers,
up to the promises
of contemporary synthetic
biology today.
Far from being solely
sensational or merely curiosities,
these claims to have
synthesized new forms of life
when we examine them collectively
and historically all
share a similar structure.
The most recent of these
are all cast in the tense
of the future perfect, that
we've not yet created life
but we will have done
so someday soon.
The creation of life in the
test tube is always imminent,
but it's also always proved to
be deferred as our understanding
of life shifts from cell to
protein, to gene, to DNA and so on.
What we once thought was
the next obvious step
that would finally reveal the secret
of life with the creation of life
in the test tube as the
principle is always deferred.
As we heard from Matt this
morning, we're still a long way
from the first functioning
protocells.
So understanding the structure,
the history of these claims,
may give us some valuable
insights into the prospects
for any future synthesis of life
and, more to our point here,
I want to suggest we can learn
something from this history
that might help us
understand our current position
in astrobiology in a new way.
After all, we haven't
found life yet,
but we will someday or
at least we hope to.
And the discovery of life in other
elsewhere's is always imminent.
So as we hope to realize a more
perfect future we should see what we
can gain from analyzing these
claims of the future perfect
in synthesizing life and in
discovering it beyond the earth.
And since I'm a Historian the
way that I do this is by thinking
through some cases, and so I'd like
to share some cases from my research
in this very earlier history
of origins life research
and history of genetics.
So history is not in the prediction
business, I'm sorry to say,
but I hope to show it can
be good to think with here.
So 60 odd years after Crosse's
electrobiological experiments brings
us to another set of experiments
that were also described
as sensational.
And these involved the new
phenomena of radioactivity,
in the hands of a curious
Cavendish laboratory physicist
and again it's the physicist
there, J. Butler Burke.
Burke, like Crosse, was
something of a one-hit wonder
when it came to great experiments.
His 15 minutes of fame
came in the summer of 1905.
Plunk a bit of radium chloride or
bromide from an ordinary test tube
into sterilized beef gelatin
or bouillon, Burke said,
nothing more than beef tea,
as one observer reported,
and the result was strange
growths in the medium.
Over the course of their existence
these growths were found to grow
in the dark, decay in
sunlight, multiply by division
and even it appeared show the
structure of the nucleus of a cell
with the attendant
phenomena of karyokenesis,
the movement of chromosomes.
Something queer has happened in his
bouillon, reported some observers.
This got reported fairly early on.
I took the story on the
right-hand column there
and blew it up so you could read it.
So unlike some of his contemporaries
who were engaged in projects aimed
at mimicking some fundamental
life processes in inorganic media,
he didn't just want to
mimic life, he wanted to get
at its underlying features.
And he held that his
experiments showed a kind
of physical metabolism,
as he called it,
somewhere between accretion
and assimilation.
It was clear to him that what he
had produced were not bacteria
or recognizably life as we know it,
they were something
else all together.
Neither radium nor microbe,
Burke took these radiobes
to be a new transitional form, not
quite living but exhibiting many
of the characteristics
essential to life here.
Burke's experiments in artificial
life, and he uses that term
as his own, and the claims he
made for it were quite modest
when compared with the enormous stir
that his experiments had aroused.
He published his findings
in Nature in 1905, but time
and again the newspapers
were reporting
that Burke was getting
at the secret of life.
According to the Daily
Chronicle these radiobes existed
in the critical state of
matter between the mineral
and the vegetable, in
fact, on the borderline
between the living and the dead.
According to the New York
Times these creatures were
on the frontiers of life where
they trembled between the inertia
of an inanimate existence and the
strange throb of insipient vitality.
They were the prehistoric ancestor
of the microbe, the Times reported.
Another newspaper reported
that Burke had succeeded
in producing cultures bearing
all the semblance of vitality.
Radium, with its half-lives
, had produced radiobes
that were themselves half alive.
Burke, himself, noted that the
radiobes appeared possess many
of the qualities and properties
that enabled them to be placed
in the borderland, so to speak,
between crystals and bacteria.
Organisms, in the sense in
which we've employed the word,
and possibly the missing link
between the animate
and the inanimate.
Although they, quote, obviously
lie all together outside the beaten
track of living things,
yet they were, he said,
within the realm of biology.
The question of whether these
microscopic forms described are
or are not living things, he
says, depends all together
on what our conception of
life is and upon how broad
or narrow is the definition
that we're willing to accept
of the phenomena of vital processes.
So, while Crosse with his electrical
mites had produced obviously living
things, just what Burke had
produced was eminently contestable
and his discovery was
described as one
that has provoked more
discussion perhaps than any event
in the history of science
since the publication
of the Origin of Species.
Had he produced living things
or only life-like things?
Any claim to have produced life
in the laboratory would be
controversial by this point,
an example of mostly
discredited theories
of spontaneous generation
by around 1900.
And, as he himself noted, to expect
to make a full-blown bacillus
at the present day
would not be more absurd
than to try to manufacture a man.
But to bring about certain
phenomena by the action of radium
that approached the
properties of a living thing,
that approximated life was
to be properly scientific
and might even give insights
into other realms in biology.
Burke held, in fact, that
his radiobes gave insight
into a potential angle for
research into the origin of life
in the distant and remote past.
In his 1906 book about his
experiment, The Origin of Life,
Its Physical Basis and Definition,
he described how his
radium based approach,
and radium was all the rage in 1904,
meant that there was now
experimental access to the question
of the historical origin of
life, there was a new way
of reading what he
called an obliterated page
in the history of our planet.
Simply put, the early earth must
have been more intensely radioactive
so there would have
more radium available
to act upon the earthly
bouillon in such a manner,
so maybe primordial soup is out
but this is even before
the primordial soup,
we have this bouillon here.
So this planetary conception
for the origin of life was seen
by a wider readership at the time as
essential to understanding the place
of life in the universe
more generally.
It's more than probable, The Daily
Chronicle said, that radium is one
of the ABCs of the stepping
stones to a law of cosmic life.
So these are the so-called
radiobes and these are the images
that he publishes in his book.
And our standards for presenting
images have changed quite a bit
since 1905, but I thought you
might like to see what it is
that he had presented, that he
showed as evidence of these growths
that grew and subdivided.
So introducing a half living
thing that possessed, he said,
N minus 1 of the N
properties of living bacilli,
Burke was broadening the
understanding of what it would mean
to study the emergence of life
on earth or in the universe.
Now he's not the best role model
for scientific success and he ended
up going a little bit
off the deep end,
but by 1931 he had written a book
on the subject, entitled perfectly
for our purposes here,
The Emergence of Life.
Now I wouldn't exactly recommend
that you read this book,
it's rather far from the
mainstream even for his day,
but in this little case study
of his early experiments
that we're seeing here
is the very beginning
of an experimental approach
into the historical origin
of life on the early earth.
And the question of the emergence
of life here is already placed
into what we might today call
an astrobiological context.
I find that fascinating and
delightful and terribly relevant
for us as we consider what we might
learn from the history of attempts
to create novel forms of life
through laboratory experimentation
and what we think we can come
to know about the existence
of life elsewhere in the universe.
Let me move ahead with the
story, through some other figures
in the history of attempts to
create life in the test tube as part
of our efforts to truly
understand the nature of life.
There are lots of investigators
we might point to in this time
and the sheer number of
attempted and failed attempts
at artificial life led one author in
Scientific America in 1911 to say,
from time to time we're
informed that the riddle
of the universe has been solved by
the artificial production of life
from nonliving materials, but each
time we wondered how it was done
for a few days and then we
find out it wasn't done at all,
the riddle is still there.
The expression artificial life
has also been used in recent years
for two entirely different
sets of ideas.
So one of them was Burke's
approach, the production of life
that never before existed,
and the other one had to do
with altering the characteristics
or the distinctive
properties of living matter.
At the top of this list was
Jacque Loeb's recent discovery
of artificial parthenogenesis,
that by changing the concentration
of salt in solutions surrounding
a sea urchin egg he was able
to cause the development of an
embryo without fertilization.
The next generation came into
existence without a father.
This most vital discovery in
the history of physiology,
almost the manufacture of life in
the laboratory, as Loeb was reported
to have said, meant that we
have drawn a great step nearer
to the chemical theory of life
and may see ahead of us a day
when a scientist experimenting
with chemicals
in the test tube may see them
unite and form a substance
which shall live and move
and reproduce itself.
Now for Loeb understanding a
phenomenon meant being able
to control that phenomenon, and
so the ultimate control over life
for him, what he called the
technology of the living substance,
was not only to be able to do with
life as one willed but eventually
to be able to create it from
scratch oneself in the test tube.
So he wasn't trying to shock
with these sorts of statements,
it was just simply
concomitant of what he viewed
as a thoroughgoing
engineering approach to life.
These sorts of exciting
claims, however,
about the newly discovered
potentials of life
and how we might engineer it,
these claims have never
been far from their publics.
By 1938 Rutmein Boyntner in his
Life is Beginning on the Earth said
that we must realize in all of these
scientific activities there are
certain rules that
cannot be neglected.
Scientists shouldn't draw suspicious
conclusions from their findings,
as for instance to say that moving
oil drops represent a form of life.
He said if they violate
this unwritten law all
of their results will be dumped
into the wastebasket of disregard,
even if real treasures
are contained therein.
Another unwritten law, he said,
by which every scientist must
abide forbids the announcement
in the lay press of unverified
results that may give rise
to general misconceptions.
The public, of course, cannot
possibly be informed on all details
of every line of scientific
research,
hundreds of which are being
pursued, and any announcement
that artificial cells have been
made may be hastily seized upon
as the dawning of a new era.
Alexander Oparin, with his
influential early theory
of coacervates as primitive
cells seems not
to have heeded this advice.
So rather than attempting a
synthetic approach to the origin
of life he argued in 1934 for
a more analytical deduction
from postulated early conditions.
He said we're faced with
this colossal problem
of investigating each separate
stage of the evolutionary process.
We have to delve into the
properties of proteins,
we must learn the structure
of colloidal organic systems,
of enzymes, of protoplasmic
organization.
The road ahead is hard and
long, but without doubt it leads
to the ultimate knowledge
of the nature of life.
The artificial building or synthesis
of living things is a very remote,
but not an unattainable
goal along this road.
So as we near mid-century
then the process
of conceptually distinguishing the
spontaneous generation of life,
the question of a historical
origin of life,
and efforts to produce
life artificially
or synthetically is nearly distinct.
The first one is entirely
out of court.
The second one is of great
interest and current research.
And the third is the eventual, but
still distant and deferred goal.
By 1953, of course, we have the
famous Urey-Miller experiment we've
heard about several times, another
approach intended to give insights.
And just as Oparin had
acknowledged but ultimately deferred
to the synthetic goal, so Miller's
experiment was also reported
in the press as heralding,
though not yet bringing
about the eventual
artificial synthesis of life.
And in the context of Herman
J. Mueller's [Assumed Spelling]
important studies on the gene
and virologists' work on viruses,
among others, genes and viruses were
increasingly seen as natural bridges
of sorts between the
living and the nonliving.
And at the same time
this increased study
of real living things became
increasingly connected to questions
of how one might engineer
such systems?
And so my point here is
that evolutionary novelty
and engineered novelty have
never been very far apart.
While J.B.S. Haldane believed
that a self-contained organism
will not be made for centuries
and N.W. Pieri [Assumed Spelling]
had provided some pretty good
criticisms by mid-century
of any attempt
to produce life artificially,
by 1964 Oparin had become more
optimistic about the possibility.
And by 1967 J.D. Barnaul
[Assumed Spelling] wrote
if life once made itself it must not
be too difficult to make it again
and elsewhere, but the final proof
remains to be found and that is
by actually making what
we're talking about.
Or as David Grinspoon has
said even more recently,
if we succeed in creating
life from scratch
in the lab we may still not know how
it actually happened historically,
but our belief that it did
happen will gain several notches
in credibility.
So such efforts in the laboratory
may well give us insights
into how life has emerged in
other times and other places.
So this brings us back then
to the world of astrobiology.
Attempts to produce life
in the test tube have
for decades been closely
associated with the quest
to understand how life may
have emerged on the early earth
or in the universe, and
this was certainly the case
in the early years of exobiology.
James Strick and Steven Dick
[Assumed Spelling] tell the story
of an exobiologist entering the new
lab at NASA Ames and being, quote,
a bit horrified to find when I first
got there a secretary answering the
telephone with, Life Synthesis.
[laughter] So from this I want to
suggest that the history of claims
for the production of life in
vetro and its discovery in astro,
both the engineering of new life
forms and the potential discovery
of new life forms elsewhere in
the universe share common futures.
And it might be useful to think
through the history of the one
in order to help understand
our position in the other.
I want to suggest that
it's not simply a matter
of finding another instance of
life, so that our understanding
of biology is not parochial as
the early exobiologists had hoped
and many of us still do,
but also of understanding
that the constant deferral
of our hopes
to have definitively located
signs of life elsewhere is a sign
of the success of our approach.
When Burke created radiobes
in the test tube the idea
of having created cell-like
forms that grew
and subdivided was later discounted
because then we thought proteins
were more fundamental to life
than just cell-like forms.
Then proteins weren't central enough
for our explanations and we began
to focus on gene centered
theories for the emergence of life.
After Arthur Kornberg's
synthesis of DNA
in the 1960s not even
the laboratory synthesis
of the hereditary material
was sufficient to hold
for long the claim that life had
just been or would soon be produced
in the test tube, although
many journalists tried.
As we get evermore knowledgeable
about how nature has evolved
and even as we become
evermore accomplished
at engineering biological systems
to obtain outcomes not seen before
in nature what we understand to be
central or fundamental or sufficient
to our understanding of life
continues to shift, as it should.
We've never been able to reach
that moment where we produce life
in the test tube because we keep
on improving our understanding of
and our ability to
manipulate living systems,
whether natural or designed.
That's a feature, not a bug.
This history of ever
constant deferral
that we might someday be able to
produce life in the test tube,
but can only produce
N minus 1 right now,
or that we might someday be able
to find life beyond the earth,
but we have only our one
local case right now,
reminds me of the Philosopher
Kant's brilliant description
of a flamenco dance -
the sudden transformation
of a strained expectation
into nothing.
[laughter] Why is it that what
seems most interesting is always
at the horizon of our understanding?
It's a consistent feature of our
efforts to understand the conditions
for the emergence and the evolution
of life in the universe and it's
that very process of resolution,
of deciding what counts
as relevant evidence or proof,
of shifting the burden of proof,
of deciding what approaches to
characterizing life we want to use,
that's actually at the
heart of what origins
of life investigators
have long done,
of what many astrobiologists today
do and what we do when we gather
at meetings like this
to refine our thinking.
So what might it mean
to use this history
that I briefly discussed
here as a tool to think
through our current
situation in astrobiology?
If claims for the synthesis
of life in vetro has
or have these constant features
of constant deferral how might this
better inform our understanding
of what we're doing when
we look for life in astro?
And so here's what I'll suggest, it
might challenge any easy assumption
that in our quest to understand
the history of life on earth
and in the universe that we will
reach clear unambiguous answers,
that the silicon giraffe will walk
in front of the Viking camera,
that the life detection experiments
will give us a clear signal,
that we'll find nano bacteria
in these Antarctic meteorites
from Mars, that we'll be able
to confirm a bio signature.
It will challenge the idea that
we should think of the search
for life beyond the earth
in the future perfect.
Now we might find silicon
giraffes, but we might not, right?
What would it look like if we
had a different development
of our science?
So rather than hoping for a
parallel aha moment of discovery,
which would be akin to
creating life in the test tube,
we can acknowledge a more
complicated and a gradual building
of knowledge and capacity
that over the course
of time fundamentally transforms
what it means to find life.
Maybe we'll find more radiobes
before we find microbes.
The fact that we haven't found life
in other elsewhere's so far then
and to use Nathaniel's wording here
then, isn't a flaw but a virtue
of our ongoing efforts to produce
and to refine our knowledge
in this compelling area of inquiry.
After all, isn't the history of
recent biology and astrobiology
in many important respects
the history of the expansion
of our understanding of life, of
the conditions for its emergence
and evolution and where
else we might find it?
And I certainly don't need to
remind this audience of our studies,
of extremophiles, of hot
springs, of deep-see vents,
of finding amino acids
in space, of our shifting
from a habitable zone idea
defined by a planet's distance
from the star, to envisioning
the ways
in which more localized
gravitational processes may provide
other sources of energy,
which might expand
where we would think
to look for life.
Ocean worlds, as we
heard about this morning,
or our many proposed theories for
the emergence of life from ribozymes
and RNA worlds, bird-like dinosaurs
and even more provocative claims
that we may be thermodynamically
downhill from an abiotic world.
The history of astrobiology
is already one
of the most remarkable stories
of scientific achievement,
but using other histories of
biology might help give us a new way
to think about our studies of life
here on earth and in the universe
as we search for these new
natures, both ones that we invent
and ones that we discover.
And, indeed, both today's
synthetic biology
and astro biology are
fields deeply concerned
with developing a comprehensive
understanding of the full potential
of living systems, with
understanding life as it could be,
and that's as true today
as it was a century ago.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Carl Zimmer: Thank you, Luis.
Our final speaker for this
session will be Sophia Roosth.
She is the Frederick S.
Danziger Associate Professor
in the Department of the
History of Sciences at Harvard.
She is an Author of
a number of articles,
and her first book is going
to be forthcoming called,
Synthetic, How Life Got Made.
And her talk today is
entitled, Analysis Synthesis.
Sophia?
>> Sophia Roosth: Good afternoon.
Bear with me while I get
my technology in order.
Historians and Ecclesiastes
be damned.
In the first decades of the 21st
Century a number of things are,
indeed, new under the sun.
Living things bearing genomes
paired down, streamlined
or cobbled together from bits
of synthesized DNA scurry,
swim and flourish in test
tubes and glass bioreactors.
These include creatures as
unlikely as viruses named
for computer software, bacteria
encoding passages of James Joyce,
and klymeric [Assumed
Spelling] yeast buckling
under the combined metabolic strain
of genes harvested from wormwood,
petunias and Icelandic microbes.
My forthcoming book,
Synthetic, How Life Got Made,
is an anthropological account
of synthetic biologists,
a group of researchers who
manufacture these novel organisms.
Now this new breed
of life scientists has
received much press attention.
I think some of these passages
are actually from Carl.
And they assembled in the last
years of the 20th Century.
Researchers from computer
science and mechanical, electrical
and chemical engineering
together resolved that if the aim
of biology was to understand how
life works then manufacturing life
would yield better theories
than would experimentation.
They advocated not experiment,
but manufacture, not reduction,
but construction, not
analysis, but synthesis.
New biotechnology techniques,
notably faster
and cheaper DNA sequencing
and synthesis have aided
them in these efforts.
In addition to techniques
and practices borrowed
from their home disciplines, they
carried with them a rich trove
of analogies and metaphors
that directed their thinking
about how to manufacture life.
So life as code or
computational logic aids,
if you ask computer scientists,
or circuits if you talk
to an electrical engineer,
perhaps as a chemical factory
for those coming from
chemical engineering.
Since I began my research synthetic
biology has grown considerably.
Its laboratories now spread across
the United States, the UK, Germany
and the Netherlands,
and at last count
over 174 American laboratories
report currently conducting
synthetic biology research.
Between 2005 and 2010
when I was doing the brunt
of my research synthetic
biological research was funded
by over $430 million dispersed by
the US Federal Government alone,
so that's not including
funding from other countries
or from private organizations.
So, like I said, I've been
studying this community since 2005
and in doing so I've participated
and observed as people, like this,
these are some of my primary
informants from Gingko Bio Labs,
worked in labs, such as this one,
this is the ND Laboratory [Assumed
Spelling], to engineer new forms
of life in the laboratory.
But to what end do they fashion
such a fantastical bestiary?
Coaxing new creatures into
recombinant life, I argue,
is a way for life scientists to make
a persuasive argument about life.
In short, synthesis
now advances analysis.
To understand their ambitions I want
to first offer a much abridged
history of 20th Century biology,
some of which you've already
heard today, but I want to do this
in order to explain precisely
what synthetic biology is not.
Since the advent of biology as a
professional discipline at the end
of the 19th Century life science has
for the most part been experimental,
but as biologists took organisms
apart, flaying flesh from limb,
in order to understand their
structure and function beginning
in the 1930s life science came
under the sway of molecular biology.
Which in investigating the
four organic molecules common
to all living things, that
is proteins, nucleic acids,
lipids and carbohydrates, stressed
above all the unity
of all life on earth.
By the start of the Cold War Jacques
Monois' [Assumed Spelling] notorious
announcement that anything found to
be true of E.coli must also be true
of elephants had sunk into a
kind of generalized common sense.
So what I'm trying to
suggest here is that for most
of 20th Century biology this has
been a project of experimentalism
that thinks of life as
something primarily mechanical
and most importantly unitary.
Life for these molecular biologists
was coherent, it was uniform,
it was even at times simple
and its essence was reduceable
to a genetic command line.
Life for synthetic biologists still
remains thoroughly materialist,
molecular and reductionist.
That being said, their approach
to studying life departs radically
from their predecessors
in molecular biology.
Take, for example, this
following definition
that two synthetic biologists gave
to their nascent field
in the pages of Nature.
They write, synthetic biologists
seek to assemble components
that are not natural,
therefore, synthetic,
to generate chemical systems
that support Darwinian
evolution, therefore, biological.
By carrying out the assembly
in a synthetic way we hope
to understand non-synthetic,
that is natural biology.
So here creating with understanding
and synthesis with analysis,
it is clear that making life for
these researchers is not an end
in itself, but rather a technique
for plumbing life's limits.
It is also, as this
quotation suggests,
a way of querying seemingly
common sense terms, like natural
and unnatural, biological
and synthetic.
And here I hope you can
hear the scare quotes
that I'm placing around
the word natural.
So I'll now hone in on a project
that MIT bioengineers launched
in the very first years of the 21st
Century, the so-called T7.1 project.
The protagonists of this story is
the minimal bacteriophage virus,
a creature so small that it is
arguably only marginally alive,
bearing a slim genome.
In 1983 T7 became one of the first
living things to be sequenced
as it weighed in at fewer
than 40,000 base pairs.
Biologists have described
such infectious agents as,
and these are quotes from
recent articles - pseudo living
or as existing on the
very edge of life.
And in the image that you're looking
at the T7 phage is what's
surrounding that large thing,
the very big spheres of bacterium.
My story begins in the mid-1990s.
A scruffy Dartmouth grad
student named Drew Endy,
a former Amtrak employee,
trained in mechanical engineering,
had recently decided to
apply his engineering skills
to living creatures.
Twenty years later Endy
would become a larger
than life charismatic
promoter of synthetic biology,
but where I begin he was merely a
frustrated grad student facing an
intractable problem.
His goal was to build
a software simulation
that would predict the behavior of
the T7 virus, which was a workhorse
of molecular biology and
genetics and continues to be one
of the most comprehensively
understood tools
of biological experimentation.
Building such a computational model
on his reasoning should effectively
verify the sum total of all
of the data that molecular
biologists had gathered
about bacteriophage since it had
first entered research laboratories
in the mid-1940s.
So the idea is that this predictive
model is going to encompass all
that we experimentally
know about the virus.
And all Endy needed to do was
computationally model the two things
that this virus can do.
And if you look at this image behind
me it diagrams what those two phases
are, that is once a bacteriophage
infects a bacterium it can either
remain burrowed within the
bacterium's genetic material
which is what you see in
the upper right-hand corner,
this is a phase called lisogeny,
or it can replicate itself,
burst through the cell's walls
and infect more bacteria,
and you see that on the left-hand
corner, this is called lysis.
Endy's computational model was,
however, an abject failure.
It was incapable of predicting
this very simple behavior of T7.
The problem haunted Endy and he took
a post doc to learn more biology.
Endy later recalled in a series
of lectures for MIT's Department
of Bioengineering, which I attended,
that those years were, as he put it,
pretty depressing to me because
now I'm coming back to this problem
where I want to understand how
this thing works and I want
to understand how this
thing works when I shuffle
up all the genetic elements.
And if I've got 72 elements and
I've got 72 factorial permutations,
more than the number of protons
in the universe probably,
and so it's not clear if I can
build-out a computer model that's
going to let me explore this,
that I'm ever going to be able
to get traction on this problem.
Simmering down his question
to its essence, Endy snapped,
what's wrong with the T7 genome?
Now I'd like to pause
here and marvel
at what bizarre question this
is for a biologist to ask.
What sort of question is it?
Is it an anthological question, is
it a normative one, is it ethical?
Wrong to whom or wrong
by what metric?
Here is precisely where
the engineer's penchant
for synthesis meets
biological analysis.
By his logic his own failure was
nothing less than a failure of all
of experimental discovery
based biology.
All the knowledge that had
been painstakingly gathered
by classical geneticists,
molecular biologists and virologists
over the course of 60 years of
laboratory experimentation was
to him simply not enough to
predict the behavior of an organism
so simple that it's arguably
only marginally alive.
Endy's proclamation that
T7 was wrong meant for him
that the virus was
disorganized, that it was cluttered
with genetic junk, and we already
heard about junk DNA earlier today.
It resisted his best efforts to
simulate, model or understand it.
So, in short, it was badly designed
and so he set about redesigning it.
Upon his arrival at MIT Endy
tasked two of his grad students
with rebuilding the genetic
material of the virus, itself,
in hopes of manufacturing a virus
simple enough that it might accord
with computational models.
And I want to make sure
everyone gets this,
so I'm going to repeat it.
The computational simulation
didn't work,
so instead of scrapping the model
they're going to modify the virus,
itself, to accord with the model.
The very fact that these researchers
choose to rebuild the physical virus
to conform to a model and not
vice-versa suggests the lack
of a coherent and meaningful
substrate
for this kind of biological inquiry.
Unable to understand how a living
thing works they remade it in order
to make it easier to understand.
Engineered organisms,
as we will see,
now function as proofs of concept.
Demonstrations of accumulated
biological knowledge,
as well as science about what about
life remains to be discovered.
The logic goes like this, the best
way to prove a biological theory
or learn more about
how life works is
to build a new organism
from scratch.
So if I were to put this in
Aristotelian terms of logical proof
such thinking is neither deductive
nor inductive or if you're going
to follow semiotician Charles
Sanders Persse [Assumed Spelling],
it's not even abductive,
rather this is a logical proof
that is being forward
constructively.
But back at MIT in 2002 this
task fell to two grad students.
The first was Shiram
Kasseri [Assumed Spelling],
a new doctoral student
in bioengineering
who had just done a degree
in biology from Berkeley,
and Leon Chan [Assumed Spelling],
who was a senior graduate student
in MIT's Department of Biology.
And what happened was this, armed
with new biotechnology techniques,
like faster and cheaper DNA
sequencing and synthesis,
they set about redesigning
the viral genome.
Their first step, and you don't have
to understand what's happening here,
I'll walk you through it, the first
step was to take the entire genome
and separate overlapping
elements from one another.
The idea was that these
overlapping elements would code
for separate proteins and that
these genes should be able
to be manipulated independently
of one another.
The reasoning is
that a well-designed
genome should be modular.
And once they had separated
out those overlapping
elements they began
to successively delete those genes
that had no known function in order
to generate a virus that would
bear what they considered
to be only the minimal number
of genes necessary for life.
So, to clarify, there are 60
genes in bacteriophage T7,
35 as of right now have a known
function, and they decided
to cut the remaining
25 to see what happens.
In their published paper
Kasseri and Chan posed a question
to their readers, they said should
we also expect that the design
of an evolved organism would be
further optimized for the purposes
of human understanding
and interaction?
This virus obviously predates
humans by a long shot.
So should it be optimized
for human understanding?
Evidence drawn from fields
outside biology suggests
that the answer is no.
After hearing numerous synthetic
biologists pose this same question,
I began to ruminate on
what life has become
when it is something
amenable to rational design.
What sort of rhetorical
possibilities are conditioned
by this application
of design to life?
By 2005 MIT grad students had, and
here I'm borrowing the terminology
of computer scientists, refactored
and rebooted the T7.1 virus,
which they named T7.1
following software nomenclature.
So follow me now into their
laboratory to peer at this sort
of unlikely creature they
had brought into existence.
So here you see four Petrie dishes.
On the left is an unengineered,
that is a wild type of virus
and it's flourishing in
the bacterial culture.
On the right you see the
engineered T7.1 virus,
which has infected the same
kind of bacterial culture.
Notice that the bacterial plaques
bearing the reengineered virus are
puny and sparse.
Simply put, T7.1 is much worse than
its naturally occurring predecessor
at doing precisely what these
viruses have evolved to do,
which is infect bacteria, replicate
itself, burst open the host, repeat.
If natural selection is the
gradual modification of an organism
to be better suited to its
environment then what is good design
if better genomes make
worse viruses?
Before I could ask my
interlock heeders this question,
they asked me.
A few months after the
bacterial plaques had been grown
in the lab I went out for
dinner with Endy and some
of his grad students at a restaurant
just off of the MIT campus.
And as plates of appetizers
were cleared away
and the wine glasses were refilled
Endy asked me this question,
which I had myself been pondering
- he said is there an environment
that would naturally
give rise to T7.1?
This question was a provocation
and a test, he was tangling
with questions of nature and
artifice and evolution and design.
And I paused for a moment to think
about it before replying, well, yes,
it's called a synthetic biology lab.
And Endy laughed approvingly
and he says, great,
that's exactly what I say when
people pose the same question to me.
And he continued and he
says, so in nature, right,
the wild type one is totally going
to rock - this is a direct quote -
whereas, in my lab this
one is going to survive,
meaning this engineered one, but the
other one isn't going to survive.
So by synthetic biologist's logic
biological fitness is defined not
by adaptability but
by comprehensibility.
Synthetic biologists as engineers
bending design principles
to living form build living systems
that are more suited
to human understanding.
As biological making converges with
biological knowing or if you want
to use $10 words, as techni
[Assumed Spelling] joins episteme,
a well-designed organism is one that
is optimized for human understanding
and most evolved organisms
just don't pass
that comprehensibility test.
The rational for such thinking I
believe is the circularity built
into this merging of making and
knowing, that is composition
for synthetic biologists
furthers biological understanding,
but sometimes composition is
also guided by understanding
as itself a design principle.
So to clarify that many synthetic
biologists, quote Richard Feynman,
a famous physicist who wrote on
his Cal Tech chalkboard the day
of his death, and you
can see the quote right
in the upper left-hand corner.
He said what I cannot
create I do not understand.
But in the case of T7.1 a more
accurate pronouncement would be I
only create what I can understand.
But otherwise when making new
biological things becomes the path
by which biology is best understood,
then understandable biological
things get preferentially made.
Exegeses becomes its
own evolutionary force.
The unlikely lives borne by
synthetic biologists grow
and mutate, metabolize
and divide and synapse,
yet they also speak eloquently of
nature and artifice, of analysis
and synthesis, of theories
of life and their limits.
And, so to close, I want to expand
outward from this case to speak
to synthetic biology more broadly.
This approach to knowing life
by remaking it inhabits a
different sort of epistemic space
than the other methods
typical of the life sciences,
namely and as I said earlier
it's not deductive or inductive,
it is at times indebted to things
like collection, classification
and experimentalism, which
are the traditional methods
of the life sciences.
But it does not neatly
align with the kind
of practically driven design and
manufacturer that one associates,
for example, with the biotech
industry or with pharmaceuticals.
Rather, it's something in
between, it is interested making,
by which I mean making
with a question attached,
it is a way of theorizing
the biological.
The objects of this manufacture
incarnate and exemplify answers even
as they point toward as
yet unasked questions.
And, in fact, I would further posit
that such active interested making
is not limited to T7 or even
to synthetic biology, but
rather is endemic to the natural
and social sciences of our moment.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Carl Zimmer: Well,
thank you, Sophia.
With three such rich talks we
have gone way over schedule,
and so the plan is we're
going to break for lunch now.
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.